There is a lot that we still don't know about the
shooter in Georgia who tragically killed eight
people at a massage parlor on Tuesday, but it
increasingly seems that the early claims that race
was not a motivating factor for the shooter. Those
claims appear to be falling apart, including based
on some new witness testimony given to a South
Korean newspaper that has been covering the story.
So to catch everybody up. The suspect is a 21 year
old male. He is alive. He was taken into custody
on Tuesday after this horrific shooting at a
massage parlor in Georgia that left at last count,
eight dead and one injured. And police have had
a chance to interview him. This doesn't always
happen in these situations where the shooter,
either at their own hand or at that of the police,
often will end up dead. Not the case here.
Police speak to the shooter. And the initial
belief by many was this was clearly an anti Asian
hate crime. This was an individual targeting Asian
individuals. But then it wasn't so clear. And it
it it could be partially that and partially what
they are describing as sex addiction, which I'm
hearing in cell, is someone who's involuntarily
celibate. But the point is, I have no interest
in prematurely saying it's one thing or the other
or neither or both. What I know
is that the law enforcement,
law enforcement in the U.S. and the American right
will often characterize shootings by white men
differently than they characterize shootings by
nonwhite men that we know. And because of that,
we're sort of on alert as we hear and try
to determine what the motive was here. And
there is no question that people often
will play coy with terms like terrorist
lone wolf and these other types of terms. In this
case, it's just early. It's a tragedy either way.
But we know most of the victims are Asian.
Now, yesterday, there was a very strange press
conference with some of the police. And I'm going
to play a clip for you of Captain Jay Baker of the
Cherokee County Sheriff's Office saying that the
shooter had a bad day and he was at the end of his
rope on the day that he killed eight people. And
many people rightly reacting by saying this guy,
the guy from the Cherokee police, Jay Baker,
he almost sounds like more sympathetic to the
shooter than to the victims in some strange way.
Take a look at this video with investigators.
They interviewed him this morning and they
got that impression that, yes, he understood
the gravity of it and he was pretty much
fed up at the end of his rope. And and
yesterday was a really bad day for him.
And this is what he did. And he was OK,
I'm not going to go to I don't know if
he was remorseful or not. I would think
he was fed up and had a really bad day and killed
eight people. Just kind of strange language for
describing what happened. It almost sounds, again,
more sympathetic to the shooter than the victims.
I think that's the bizarre thing. But OK,
maybe race wasn't a factor. We don't know yet.
And then maybe not shockingly, after
this bizarre press conference, we learn
that Jay Baker, the Georgia sheriff's spokesman
you heard from there, has previously posted
xenophobic covid shirts on Facebook where he said
he loves his shirt. And the shirt is a shirt that
says covid-19 imported virus from China. So why
hyphen and a so now maybe we're doubting what this
guy says. And then we get reporting from the South
Korean newspaper Chozen, which interviewed victims
and reports that the Atlanta shooter said to a
witness or a witness heard the shooter say, I'm
going to kill all Asians. And we've translated the
article from Korean. The reporter is Huang Zhijun.
It includes reports of interviews with witnesses
and the quote that on the 17th, the Hankuk Ilbo,
Atlanta quoted an employee, a a member of the
gold massage spa where the shooting took place
and said that the suspect at the time of the
crime said that he would, quote, kill all Asians.
It is known that this witness, Mr. AI, was in
the store at the time of the shooter shooting,
but managed to evacuate and then gave this
information to nearby Korean businesses. So
it's becoming harder and harder to believe that
a guy saying he's going to kill all Asians wasn't
at least partially motivated by race. Here
is another clip in this one. Frank Reynolds,
a Cherokee County sheriff, says that this appears
to be sexual addiction, not racism. Take a look.
We did interview on. Last night, he is currently
in our facility at the Turkey County Adult
Detention Center. We were able to interview
him with the Atlanta Police Department and FBI.
He made indicators and indicators that
he has some some issues potentially
sexual addiction and may have frequent some of
these places in the past. And but as the chief
indicated, it is still early on. We still have a
lot of things to process. And so he should be at
an arraignment tomorrow at sometime early morning
to late morning. And we will keep you up to date.
We have a press release that Captain Baker
has put together available to our media folks.
If you don't have that, I think we have some
colonoscopies that he'll be happy to give to you.
I'm happy to answer any questions that you may
have. So are you saying we talked to a special
edition victim, but I'm sure you ask them, was it
racially motivated or was this racially motivated?
As the chief indicated, it's still
early. But the indicators right now are
it may not be it may be targets of
opportunity. Again, we are we believe
that he frequent these places in the past and he
may have been lashing out. And part of that is,
is in your media packet as well. But the working
theory is a sexual addiction issue rather than a
racial profiling. During our interviews, we ask
that specific question, and that did not appear
to be the motive for the complaint. Thank you.
Now, according to authorities, the suspect
intended to also target the pornography industry
in Florida before he was apprehended. And again,
the statements, there's a claim that the shooter
said I wasn't motivated by race or politics. I
was motivated by my addiction to sex. The claims
from the witness about I'm here to kill all Asians
certainly seem to contradict that. Now, I
don't know that it necessarily has to be
one or the other. You could have someone who
I guess the term Insull is sort of pejorative,
but it's an individual frustrated by
his by his celibacy. They're celibate,
but they don't want to be celibate. And for a
variety of different reasons, they're unable to
find relationships with. If you're interested in
the opposite sex, as it appears this person was
members of the opposite sex, it could be both. It
could be racially motivated and in some motivated
or more one or more the other. So whether or
not this was racially motivated, there have been
many racially motivated shootings. Whether this
one is racially motivated doesn't change that.
Racially motivated shootings are a problem in
the United States. Some people immediately said,
of course, this is racially motivated and anyone
saying otherwise is lying to you or dishonest.
Others have been saying there's no way this is
racially motivated and we shouldn't look for that.
Even some on the left. In fact, I've been saying
stuff like that. From what we know so far,
there is certainly reason to suspect that race
was one of possibly more than one motivation.
Let's continue to allow the information to lead
us to the answer. I have no political or emotional
attachment to it being one or the other. But
what we do know is there at least now is a report
of the shooter saying, I'm here to kill all
Asians. We will see what comes out. We'll see what
else we learn about this sheriff's spokesperson
who posted xenophobic China shirts to Facebook.
Every every detail continues to
just be more and more alarming.